cinq minutes avant d'entrer en scène le
dj français est collé à son smartphone
mais ce n'est toujours pas pour mettre
au point sa playlist
[Applaudissements]
est vrai tu peux demander à quoi tu
penses avant de monter sur scène ouais
et là il ya une fuite dans mon évier
dans mon appartement j'ai pas d'eau
quand je rentre alors je suis avec le
plombier
et on s'aperçoit dans l'histoire que
tous les régimes totalitaires
dictatoriaux ont voulu soit empêcher les
gens de faire de la musique c'est le cas
des talibans aujourd'hui en afghanistan
ou bien contrôler quels types de musique
il produisait mais tout simplement parce
que la musique au fond c'est quelque
chose qui va augmenter chez les humains
la capacité à la spontanéité à la
sensualité à l'envi d'échangés et ça les
dictatures évidemment n'aime pas du tout
le discours qui était il ya quelques
mois ils jeunes ont besoin de s'amuser
je suis désolé je fais partie peut être
d'une autre génération la jeunesse ou
c'est l'engagement la jeunesse c'est
l'action et si les jeunes pensent que ça
fait pas gauche ce que je dis c'est les
anarchistes qui disait ça les vieux à la
tombe les jeunes à l'action c'est un de
mes oncles qui a écrit ça au pérou
trop de bonheur sur le plateau peut
nuire bien sûr lors questions france
d'offrir merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
une semaine après le choc place aux
soupçons
[Applaudissements]
ils sont plus d'un millier à manifester
ce samedi à paris la révocation du droit
à l'avortement par la cour suprême des
etats-unis est dans toutes les têtes ce
qui se passe aux etats unis sa montre
encore une fois que le droit à
l'avortement bas c'est un droit qui
n'est pas forcément acquis et qu'il faut
continuer à se mobiliser dans tout le
monde
non
sow
à l'idée n'est pas bête hein d'ailleurs
robert hossein l'avait déjà plus ou
moins avancés dans son livre lumière et
ténèbres peut-être faudrait-il faire
passer à nos chefs politiques un examen
qui évaluerait leur aptitude à la
compassion et à la bonté les deux
joueurs se seraient embrassés sous
l'objectif des photographes pour
protester contre l'interdiction des lgbt
de l'homosexualité au qatar pendant la
coupe du monde c'est faux c'est d'un
compte parodique qui a partagé ce cliché
il ya quelques semaines un photomontage
photomontage publiés pour la première
fois en octobre dernier sur instagram
par tata qui c'est un média belge vous
gagnez 20 mille euros que voulez vous en
faire kevin alors j'aimerais emmener les
deux garçons au qatar pour la coupe du
monde en fin d'année si c'est possible
c'est or c'est bien de corriger parce
que sur ma vie j'ai raté ils aimeraient
assister à un match de la coupe du monde
à dubaï alors à touba les amphis orages
sont séparés en géographie aussi hors
dubaï c'était plutôt thé des gens qui
ont rien dans le crâne et qui font des
trucs sur internet mais sinon le
football ça se passera plutôt au qatar
vous savez à quoi on reconnaît une
lamborghini à la carrosserie bien sûr
aux finitions intérieures aussi et
surtout aux bruits de son moteur et
alors là pour tout vous dire on a quand
même quelques doutes sur l'authenticité
du véhicule ah ouais on va le truc est
tellement génial qui ont il ya quand
même quelqu'un qui l'a volée ouais faut
avoir l'idée quand même donc ça fait
deux mètres de haut s'était dans les
alpes bavaroises après liste allemande a
ouvert une enquête deux mètres de haut
oui oui c'est vrai tu le met où mais
alors là ne compte pas sur moi pour
donner une réponse là mais je sais dans
mr c'est quand même difficile à rentrer
dans la maison à la
[Musique]
côté face un enfant mise au ban de la
cour d'école moqué pour sa tâche au
visage
à la maison jamais il ne s'est plaint il
a toujours été très réservée la suisse
voulait pas ouvrir le pen
la première question ça a été c'est quoi
pourquoi tu as cette tâche
la cour de récréation il y avait le
petit legros et moi j'étais la tâche
noah tête d'un enfant ça reste à tout
jamais ça bah ouais ils m'énervent le
mec du bon là depuis tout à l'heure une
présence celle où tu as l'habitude parce
que c'est et on met lui c'est pas de ta
faute il s'est même pas physique c'est
laura tu dégages que celle où
une fois au mon ami angela merkel venait
me rendre visite à paris je suis dit je
vais te montre un tableau extraordinaire
vous soumets
donc qu'est ce que j'avais pas fait
nicolas nicolas
mais je dise un tableau ne soit pas
choqué c'est l'origine du monde nicolas
cycle ya pas de photos parce qu'elle
n'avait jamais vu vous souvenez
absolument
avec beaucoup d'attention vous aviez
éloigné d'ailleurs la presse
en ville la pudeur leur impose de
s'enfermer dans un vieux clou
l'affirmer mais on est très à l'aise
comme si qu'on était à la maison en fait
y'a pas de barrière il n'y a pas de
jugement il n'y a pas de choses comme ça
parce que je sais que la miette et
pudique et vient de l'est moyen du sud
est l'est de l'allemagne de l'est moi je
suis de la méditerranée donc franchement
c'était l'iceberg et la chaleur alors
face à l'origine du monde moi j'étais
enthousiaste est comme ça